so last year yours truly hosted a
comic-con panel they hooked us up with a
professional badge not quite a press
badge it was my first time ever
attending comic-con when we were waiting
in all these long lines talking to all
our friends who have significantly less
followers than us who had press badges
we were like you know what we get back
we should apply for press badges and we
got approve this year it goes right yeah
but then some stuff happened this year
so now our privileged asses gotta enjoy
it for free along with the rest of you
at home remote what a waste of press
badge that way that's okay
I honestly did a comic-con is not really
at the same time still it's not like oh
thank god we could just stay back and
watch trailers through if they happen to
premiere there because that was such a
big anxiety in mind it was like well you
can go over to the conference's what if
I want to watch the trailers record a
reaction on YouTube because that's kind
of where my heart fair enough to me
see the crowds and all that I just is
not really my thing in some ways I'm
looking forward to this new virtual con
home thing cosmic wonder I saw his title
show up with my notifications breaking
San Diego comic-con dates free virtual
comic-con home let's see what's in store
how's it going everybody gets warned
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talked about everything
Marvel and everything relating to the
MCU and today we have some excellent
news as San Diego comic-con has
officially announced its dates now of
course as everybody knows San Diego
comic-con is pretty much the biggest
event of the year for us it's where we
get a ton of information not just about
Marvel but all things in general Star
Wars and DC really is just a huge
convention last year we got the entire
Marvel phase four slate revealed to us
plus Kevin Feige mentioned the x-men and
the Fantastic Four so everyone was
really looking forward to this year
rushing back to the hotel with at home
so now we have the official dates for
San Diego comic-con at home
Steve Weintraub from Collider has
tweeted breaking San Diego comic-con at
home will be held on the same dates as
the previously canceled Comic Con July
22nd through July 26 mataji raise rates
they're promising panels and
presentations about comics gaming film
and a wide variety of topics from
publishers studios and more now this is
very exciting but let's talk about what
we can expect from Marvel at San Diego
comic-con at home obviously there's a
lot of hope that we're going to get some
decent reveals specifically regarding
the trailers for the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier and the one division
series and although we're very hopeful
that we'll get these trailers we
shouldn't get our expectations too high
because it sounds like San Diego home is
going to be kind of like WonderCon
online which was a really big
disappointment to a lot of people and
there weren't really any reveals or
releases from Marvel Studios now
comic-con at home
not yet 100% confirmed that Marvel will
have a panel in fact they could decide
to do their own panel online separate
from comic-con at home but this is the
big comic-con and no doubt Marvel was
going to appear in Hall age at San Diego
comic-con
if the coronavirus wouldn't have
canceled it so stay tuned I'll report
any and all things that I hear about
Marvel Studios at Comic Con at home and
in the meantime you can tune in on July
22nd through July 26 for free and see
what they have to offer be sure to
subscribe to my channel so you don't
miss out on any updates about comic-con
at home and so you can enter this week's
giveaway to win a Deadpool Funko pop be
sure to like this video and for live
updates you can follow me on Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof woof woof talk about
this I don't know anything about the
Wonder Kong crap that happened just
conventions have never really been my
thing
the bummer of the situation that I think
ensues is for everyone who's not me
being the room I think the site scene of
comic-con is really cool just for me I'm
not a big fan of that level of crowd and
the heat and all that comes with it I'm
torn when I'm at an event like that
because I'm like what brought me here is
the following on the real rejects and
everyone wants to tray the reactions and
I feel like I needed to liver on that
tent to the subscribers and that some
people will be like don't you want to
experience the press conferences and all
that I'm like yeah we got some crappy
ass seats always come back some other
time but the trailer now I want to
experience that and share that with the
crowd I don't want to watch it that
there and then go into a hotel and then
film it and be disingenuous about
whatever is exciting about that I know
it might sound silly to you guys but it
means a lot to me however for this Comic
Con situation it's a smart move right
now it's the safest move I feel so I
might object especially when you have
all these protests going on worldwide
really but how could we can't gather for
this this is something we can hold off
on guys
and not life or death yeah and I think
the winning part of it is it's gonna be
free so everyone can access it everyone
can access it in real time and
experience whatever low-five version of
comic-con this is gonna be it's a bummer
for those who really
and like a year in advance for their
tickets car travel they assemble a
friends their hotels they all booked
really early in advance well I was one
thing I really did love about it
actually was witnessing and feeling the
energy of all those who are very
passionate and embracing their geekdom
and there's like some fun things you
can't absolutely check out I wish I
shared that level of it's like my
girlfriend gcamp sat in college every
single year like she's excited we could
go with the hood so like for her it's a
real bummer
for her it pains her and for me now
hopefully we'll have some trailers to
watch so on my selfish side that
pathetic side I get it that being said I
mean it's cool that everyone gets to
experience this free and also like I do
think we'll get some Marvel trailers
they say I feel like this is every year
now don't they
morbol might not be there like they were
not there once and then DC just took the
place of them yeah yeah that was because
Infinity Ward come out and then want any
spoilers or anything so like less sense
they're totally gonna be there and if we
end up getting there like some of their
own Marvel panel online actually that
worked yeah we can all log in and the
band without a crash or anything like
that from just the amount of traffic
that's something they're really gonna
have to deal with like I can see
something's going wrong in this
presentation yeah but the idea that
they're still aiming to have this go on
and for it to be celebrated and we're
gonna get some cool stuff movie studios
really do rely on on the hype there the
thing though is big part of the hype
that comes into play with comic-con is
when crowds are at the panel's mm-hm and
you're able to feel the energy
everyone's tweeting before anyone can
see anything online everyone's freaking
out
dropping information the press members
like Steve Weintraub heard this just
happen you know that level of
anticipation and excitement and what's
being teased to them that's it's a
enthralling them is now being conveyed
via social media so it's all working in
this big hub and
you just can't get that this time around
you can't we're all just gonna be
responding then it's like it's just like
covering movie news now oh you know yeah
yeah and I mean I don't know I'm curious
to see what kind of innovations they
bring to this because they have to be
aware if WonderCon online wasn't a very
successful or very well-received venture
I have to imagine that especially
planning this and having a literate of
time to consider it they're going to
want to step it up and make it at least
something that can border on making up
for the experience I'm not having
comic-con and I have some faith in them
especially because you know WonderCon is
a big event by all accounts but San
Diego comic-con is like this juggernaut
that does have so much Giants support
from outside Studios and forces and
stuff that all rely on that to to stoke
the fire of their you know rollouts for
their movies and their comics and
content so yeah I am very curious to see
what's gonna happen here I definitely
think that there are gonna be some bug's
to work out it's not gonna be perfect
but I don't know here's hoping that they
make this something that could maybe
even prove itself worthwhile enough to
maybe be a part of comic-con when they
do allow people to attend physically
again in the future maybe this could be
a clever way of cutting down on some of
the overcrowding yeah different aspects
like that so that's also what I look
forward to out of this is maybe we'll
get some new facet of comic-con that
we'll have to look forward to next year
in the year after that'll make it easier
for folks like us if we don't
necessarily have the means or the needs
to be there yeah so yeah I don't know
this could be cool wait and see how it
goes but I don't think the big ones are
gonna go just like peace out and not
mention anything at all or drop no news
but I did love hosting a panel that was
pretty rad I'll do that again
Marvel they're fun don't have to go tell
people really think I like would love
coffee I don't like I don't really like
conventions just generally I mean my
biggest bummer is like I just love to go
around and look at the artists alleys so
I'm gonna miss that yeah but you know
the rest of it you know I'm sure I'll
find some and I figured enough
memorabilia to break my bank all right
guys well I know so many you guys have
not been able to go to come most people
have not gone to comic-con
on earth so what do you think about this
news does it excite you at all thank you
to Warren for putting this together
subscribe to cosmic one or subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
Bell last but not least Mikhail Linden
Mikhail our beautiful friend from Sweden
I know recently even hit with some very
hard times and you haven't taken a
little bit of a step back from the
patreon after this month which I totally
understand I get the world's been kind
of cruel to you in so many ways bond
getting delayed I know that's the
biggest bummer of the mall then some
other stuff happened this year but that
it's I understand you're a song and
everything nah man I get that when you
have to take a break you got to take a
break and you got to get your own
personal stuff in order please
understand that even though you've been
one of our top tier pledge patrons for
such a long time that you have to do
this whole no ill-will
whatsoever I don't hate you at all
I have no bit of resentment towards you
in this process
I am fully supportive of you getting
your crap together her real life even if
it slightly affects us and you didn't
send me a four-page text about how angry
you are with McKellen how much you wish
he would just fall down a flight of
stairs or something did not did not
definitely didn't and I didn't read it
and go yeah sure is coffee you're giving
him Kovac doesn't see what you're doing
McHale but it's okay it's okay take care
of yourself it's all good hopefully it's
comic-con news cheers you I love you
buddy be safe